- [Narrator] In early 2019,
Robert Pattinson was announced
as the new cape crusader
for Matt Reeves' highly
anticipated adaptation,
The Batman.
And well, the internet,
they had thoughts.
(shouting)
- Noooooo!
- [Narrator] Which is pretty
much par for the course
whenever someone is cast in a Batman movie
or any superhero movie.
- It's like, "Ben
Affleck's gonna be Batman."
The first reviewer goes,
"Noooo!"
(laughs)
- [Narrator] And being
as Robert Pattinson's
most recognizable role to date was this...
- This is the skin of a killer, Bill.
- [Narrator] We can understand
the initial skepticism.
More recently, though,
that skepticism has shifted
to cautious optimism
as people have discovered
the non-Twilight parts
of Pattinson's career.
As the movie heads back into production,
we thought we'd ask,
how did Robert Pattinson go
from Twilight to the Batman
and why do we and a lot of initial haters
now think he's the perfect choice?
To do this, we really
have to take a look back.
Before we examine how Robert Pattinson
emerged as the front runner
in the most coveted
superhero role, like ever,
we have to examine
what makes a good
superhero on the big screen
and how that's evolved over the years.
Christopher Reeves
really kicked things off
with Superman in the late 70s.
Yeah, we're really going back that far.
But our idea of a modern day superhero
really doesn't take effect until the 2000s
when superhero movies dominated
the mainstream blockbuster season.
Prior to the 2000s, studios
looking to cast a superhero
or a superhero villain,
tended to go straight
to big name movie stars
and just put them in shiny suits.
Sometimes, those suits had nipples.
Studios thought,
if you're gonna be able
to sell these movies
to McDonald's and MasterCard,
you gotta have big names.
And, they were right.
For the most part,
big names equal big
dollars at the box office.
But when they assembled the
team for the 2000's X-Men,
the previous formula for what
made a superhero completely,
well, mutated.
By implying an inventive
mix of award winners
and prestigious actors with newcomers and
not really including any marquee names,
X-Men set itself apart from
all other superhero movies
and it was a huge success.
Okay, Halle Berry was a big time star but
she also pretty much
told us why she was cast.
And, a couple of years later, Sam Raimi,
would take that new casting
formula even further
with Spider-Man,
picking critical darling, Tobey Maguire,
no marquee name at the
time, to play Peter Parker.
After 2000, it helped
more to have an Oscar nom
than $100 million movie behind you,
if you wanted a studio
to put you in spandex.
This is not to say Hollywood
abandon the movie star
formula all together,
but as we get into the mid 2000s,
that strategy was yielding
diminishing returns.
And right as the superhero
genre is really taking off
and studios are rethinking
who to cast as their world savers,
Robert Pattinson, starts acting.
Cast as Reese Witherspoon's
son in Vanity Fair,
yes, the same Reese who
would play his love interest
just seven years later,
which is not weird at all,
Patterson's role for Vanity
Fair was unceremoniously cut
at the last minute.
The casting director for that
film reportedly felt so bad
that they cast him as the
uber-charming, Cedric Diggory,
in Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire.
- So, I was quite glad
I got cut in the end.
- [Narrator] After bouncing around
some forgettable indies,
in 2007, Robert Pattinson
audition for the role
of Edward Cullen in Twilight.
Never expecting it to be a blockbuster hit
and thinking it would just
be another forgettable indie,
Pattinson was then inadvertently thrust
into one of the biggest franchises
to ever hit tween girls'
walls and the pages of Tumblr.
- [Announcer] Get loud for Edward Cullen
(mumbling)
(cheering)
- [Narrator] Then, Twilight
began breaking records in Hall H
and at the box office, making Pattinson
the exact kind of movie star
that would have been perfect
for a superhero movie,
once upon a time.
While our paths turned
out Twilight sequels
and subtly shaded the film
and the fandom in interviews
every chance he got...
- Did your Twilight experience
turn out to be what you expected?
(deep exhaling)
- [Narrator] Over at superhero land,
something interesting is taking flight.
Marvel and Christopher Nolan,
leaned into the X-Men model
by hiring actors-actors and unknowns
and both start dominating
at the box office.
Although these are household names now,
looking back on the faces
of superhero movies from this time,
it was more of a who's who of, who's that?
Back then, Robert Downey Jr. was
mostly known for his arrest record,
Chris Hemsworth was an Aussie
with a barely there Star Trek cameo,
Jennifer Lawrence had been
nominated for an Oscar but
for a film that was out
grossed by Piranha 3D
and Henry Cavill, before Man of Steel,
he was best known for
playing the only character
to have more bed partners than
Henry VIII, on the Tudors.
But, back to our new Batman.
When Pattinson left The
Twilight Zone in 2012,
after four films and $3.3
billion at the box office,
he could essentially
do anything he wanted.
And what he wanted to do,
was work with some of
the most innovative indie
and avant garde directors out there.
He worked with names like Warner Hertzog,
David Cronenberg, David Michelle,
Claire Denis, James gray,
the Safdie brothers and Robert Eggers,
avoiding anything big
budget or high profile.
By, not auditioning, 'cause he's bad at it
and essentially hounding
the directors he admired,
Pattinson amassed an impressive
filmography of varied roles,
as well as critical acclaim
and a reputation of someone with taste
that many creative directors sought out.
This was also the moment
that studios started hiring
auteur directors to film superhero films.
This was not to say that every
effort was the Dark Knight
but, in this timeframe,
the most successful efforts
for fans and critics, shied
away from big movie stars.
And, yes, we are marking Justice League
as a lackluster effort, but we
are reserving final judgment
until we see the Snyder Cut.
If all this auteur stuff is
sounding somewhat familiar,
let us remind you of
these award winning actors
who also eventually chose to
play comic book characters,
(growling)
or at least I think
that's what Tom Hardy was doing in Venom.
I'm still not quite sure.
- Like a turd, in the wind.
- [Narrator] So this brings us around
to the time we found out Robert Pattinson
would be our next Batman.
From what we know about the Batman,
weird auteurism
and a bit of weirdness
in the cape and cowl
is exactly what the film needs.
This is not gonna be an
early 2000 superhero flick.
Rumored to follow the plot
of The Long Halloween,
this new Batman is more
of a mob detective movie.
Don't look for too many all out brawls,
which is probably a good
thing since Pattinson said
that he doesn't plan to
work out for the role.
(sighs)
Perish the thought!
With that in mind,
Pattinson's unique filmography
actually gives us a ton of evidence
as to why he was perfectly cast.
In the certified fresh High Life
as an abandoned astronaut
floating aimlessly in space,
Pattinson and showed his
ability to be captivating
in a psychological thriller
as the brooding young billionaire
riding around New York for
Cronenberg's Cosmopolis,
he gives us a tiny peek
into what he could bring
to a young Bruce Wayne.
And, as the affluent pioneer
bent on winning his lady love,
no matter the cost for Damsel,
he shows us how he can
portray Bruce Wayne's
fanatical quest to seek
justice, by any means necessary.
It's hard to know what
made Matt Reeves think
Pattinson would be perfect for the role,
well, besides a killer jawline,
but you can see how
Pattinson gained an edge by
simply being as weird as possible.
And, I mean, he was really weird.
(mumbling)
(thumping)
But again, being uber-weird
is something men who successfully
don the cape and cowl
kinda have in common.
(screaming)
I mean, we get it,
if you haven't been
following his filmography
and you heard the sparkle
vamp was gonna be Bruce Wayne,
you're likely...
- [Woman] Stop!
(clinks)
- [Narrator] But, very few
people knew that Heath Ledger
would be able to bring the
Cobb gravitas to the Joker,
that Michael Keaton could pull off
the aloof and mysterious but ultra swab,
sometimes love struck billionaire,
or that Hugh Jackman
could give a character
that he'd been playing
for almost two decades,
the heartbreaking swan song
of a warrior that's seen
way too many battles.
(sighs)
Still makes me cry.
We might have guessed that Ryan Reynolds
could have quipped and joked his way
to a pitch perfect Deadpool,
but we doubt even he thought
it would be as awesome as it was.
Chris Evans himself was
doubtful in his ability
to pull off the perpetually patriotic
and wholesome, Captain America.
And, thank God they
convinced him otherwise,
but does anyone remember the
fact that it took Ryan Reynolds
three films to get a quippy
superhero performance to work.
I'm just saying.
More than anything, what makes
Pattinson perfect for Batman
is what he's not.
Clooney, Kilmer and Affleck
brought plenty of star power
but they left fans and critics cold.
From the drunken mermaid
loving light keeper,
to the charismatic bank robber,
to the criminal astronaut,
to the hilariously offensive monarch,
to the post apocalyptic
survivor who hums pop ballads,
Pattinson has proved his dogged commitment
to finding interesting characters
no matter where they lie.
And all that work solidified
to make casting Pattinson as Batman
a compelling and inspired choice,
right around the time that Warner Brothers
was looking for a new young
actor to play Bruce Wayne.
Knowing all this, it kinda
makes sense to cast a man
who went on the Today Show
and lied about dead clowns.
- First time I went to
a circus somebody die,
one of the clowns died.
(laughs)
- [Narrator] And he totally
lied about those dead clowns.
Honestly, in the end,
the only thing I'm looking
forward to more than the film
is Pattinson on the Batman press tour.
- In the sex shop?
Batman is not a superhero.
I got a very pronounced gag reflex.
My rap's name was Big Tub.
I just always thought like,
have you ever see this
movie, Corky Romano?
I used to be friends with
all the hookers who lived down the street.
(laughs)
Sometimes.
(chuckles)
Sometimes!
- [Narrator] Let your
freak flag fly my boy.
Let it fly.